[Music]
here's my challenge each of us what's
one narrative that you think
actually you should be going counter to
that narrative
like there's a narrative that we hear as
entrepreneurs as people and kind of tech
and like what do you think is the like
actually i don't know
maybe it's this other thing instead so
if anyone has one do it but otherwise
i'll i'll give you one
yeah go for it so
mine would be um
i'll give you two there's the inside
crypto there's a narrative that's
basically like
oh there's all this innovation happening
this
it's like the next protocol the next
token the next whatever
i'm pretty sure that if you just buy
three or four things like if you buy
bitcoin eth
um
i put luna in there now just buy those
three
and you just chill either all of crypto
is gonna work and those will work
amazingly
or crypto's not gonna work and no matter
what you did like if those fail if those
don't go up dramatically in value
um crypto just didn't work and none of
this will work and so i think
actually a basically like for a while
the best strategy was bitcoin and chill
and now it's ethan chill i basically
think it's still the same i think it's
like
buying two or three tokens and not even
needing to know anything more just
chilling on those is probably the best
investment of the next like 10 to 15
years it's gonna outperform everything
during that time
i think so i think like
going deeper down the rabbit hole and
like learning more is actually gonna
up your returns versus just buying
the the main ones and just holding for
for like 10 years not thinking about it
that's one and then the other is
i think that angel investing doesn't
make much sense anymore and i say this
as somebody who angel invests
like the valuations are so high
um that like if i think about like that
same money going into like one of these
sort of boring cash flow businesses
is so much better for your life so if
you're like an individual angel investor
and you have let's say a hundred
thousand dollars
you know or 300 000 that you want to go
put into like a basket of 20 startups
it's like are you sure you shouldn't
just buy like
like get an sba loan and go buy like
some random website that's already
producing profit and that'll pay itself
off in two years or less
and uh and now you own this cash flowing
asset like i'm pretty sure that's just
going to do better dude i agree than a
basket of angel investments the the the
our friends who have all crushed it on
angel investing you know it means they
made their investments five or eight
years ago and it was different it is
it's outlandish at the moment so i agree
with that i think for mine that i think
that it's actually
i think that
i think that you only have a few swings
in your career and a lot of people are
like oh you should be patient and you've
got a lot of time to do certain stuff i
actually think you should try you should
dedicate your 20s to getting your first
significant win because after that life
gets a lot harder you get a lot less
energy you're a lot smarter which is
actually bad you actually it's kind of
good to be kind of
ignorant
um and not enough people i think all
often times people go the other route
where they go well just go join
something for a little while and learn
in my opinion f that your 20s dedicated
to getting a win and getting even if
it's relatively small and do it as fast
as possible because after that life is a
lot easier
i'll give my
what sean
i was going to say give the moise quote
about getting rich quick he goes
why does everyone hate on getting rich
quick get rich quick schemes are the
best
i want to get rich quick i don't want to
get rich slow
i got i got two real quick so
i
got off the phone with a friend of mine
who works at facebook he told me this
morning he told me that he works
roughly 90
90 to 120 minutes per day on average
i thought you're going to say 90 to 120
hours a week he yeah it's the best when
you measure your work in minutes he's
texting me he texted me today he said it
was 9 12 am he said 9 12 a.m finish work
for the day
12 12 minutes
and so
you know put us in a group chat i want
him to text us every day just the time
stamp of winning so that's what that's
what i told him to do i said you need to
create like a twitter a non account a
twitter that's and so i'm gonna
stay tuned do that um but i think that
in your 20s like
potentially go work at facebook go work
at google get those high-paying jobs
i think that by the way i think i think
that's a good way to get a win get get
you know do that for a few years
while you're
you know do you're doing your you're
learning on the side like join a tao
build a community build a newsletter do
whatever you want to do it really speaks
to you
while you're you're not
you know
yeah so you're making money and you're
learning
what more could you ask for and then my
and you know just because you gave a
crypto
uh
one sean i think that
and i spent a lot of time in nft land
and web 3 land 2.
i think that nfts are going to 99
freedom it it's going to be a free
freedom in thing i think the the idea of
selling nfts
uh
will be a very small thing
so what what happens why why would i
give away something for free or what's
my incentive so what happens after it's
freedom in so
yeah i mean you know okay so the idea
right now it's like people are selling
nfts and projects for 0.05 to 0.2 let's
say on average for some of these you
know 10 000 pfp projects
i think that um
that's going to burn out at some point
and i think we're starting to see it
burn out a little bit
and
i think that you know did you see the
hundred thieves drop
yeah they
uh what do they do exactly they did a
much smaller amount so they basically
first of all it was in gaming and gamers
hate nfts so the fact that they did a
successful gaming nft launch like
obviously kudos to them
but basically
they won this championship and they were
like okay in order to get this like
collectible you can go grab it it's free
we're not saying it's going to be worth
anything and they got 700 000 people to
collect this collectible
and
and there's like a trophy and then they
make money on
if there's value right so if it grows in
value they get royalties
and i think that's what you're going to
see a lot of is like creators and and
big communities basically doing freedom
ins
um
even though people seem you know people
today think that selling nfts is the
future i don't think so
right
by the way i'm going to change mine to
simplify it instead of starting a
company buy an existing business i think
that is the most overlooked obvious
thing for a smart person to do is
how do you take your market risk to
essentially zero um
you buy a business that's already
working and profitable and you just say
cool i'm a better operator than this
person or i know about a different form
of operation than they do and so i can
grow this using facebook ads or i can
grow this using outsourcing or i can
grow this using you know code or
whatever it is
so
you you hear almost no narrative you
heard tons of narrative around the
genius visionary startup start a new
thing building a new project launching a
new thing and like
you hear like one or two examples of
people buying businesses
and i think that for most smart people
buying a business is a far better idea
than starting yeah but when you're in
your 20s
my pushback to that is like when you're
in your let's say early 20s like do you
know
like you're saying that now
but i think like yeah
um you do need like that operational
experience and that's where my point is
um
you got to
like it's worthwhile to
to just
potentially take a a high-paying job and
then on the side kind of like experiment
and do stuff
yeah that's true i'm not really
limiting mine to the 20s i think
i'm still making mistakes in my 30s so
i'm assuming other people are too and i
guess it's more like what narrative do i
hear now that's easy to float along with
that i'm like you know what actually
i don't i don't i just think this is
true and like that's the one for me
which is like for most people who want
to be entrepreneurial they
default to starting a business and i
think actually maybe it should be the
opposite maybe you should default to
taking on an existing business and
growing it and only create a new thing
if you like actually have a new
invention in mind a new idea that really
you can't shake in your head versus like
just starting a new startup i like that
because because you want to be an
entrepreneur right
[Music]
you